[Music]
are you guys having a good time tonight
yeah I'm having a great time meeting so
many new people are just fantastic
fantastic vidcon's the place to meet
people and just really Network out it's
fantastic I'll be good oh it's great
it's fantastic to me everybody here and
you know party with the House of Blues
so yeah yeah the night has brought
Mathias so that definitely means because
he's German everyone's gonna drink a lot
more but I think tonight just brought
like like new faces friends and it's
just amazing to see like all these great
youtubers that you look up to and you
you kind of want a fangirl scream like
oh but then you kind of want to be like
I'm not crazy I'm gonna be like hey with
one end and behind my back so yeah it's
a combination of both you just like
doing great I just got here I'm raise
you a range of a con and up was what the
kids are saying these days is that it
gets clown it up come on it up like walk
on it's a big con and you just con it up
you know all will be con Ewing it to and
clowning a little bit my hand
design the garden I want to get swarmed
though there have been swarm before I
heard it's crazy we're excited to meet
grace and mamrie yeah we know Hannah I
mean very cool just seeing her recognize
that but we're from where grace and
mamrie are from so I want to connect in
the comedy scene for meteors I'm just
excited to see a bunch of youtubers in
one room what are you looking forward to
since besides drinking just you know
drinking with youtubers I'm looking
forward to meeting my dad I've never met
my real dad so I'm trying to find him
and meet him Oh at VidCon dad con 2013
is happening you heard it here first
dad con 2013 only for dads dad's only
I'm gonna like try and crowd surf across
the bar and then off the balcony already
sweaty they need the AC on mic what can
you do
[Music]
you don't know how to twerk but we try
it we would hate to speak on it it's one
of those things it's better than us to
do it and not talk about it it involves
penis choreography what are you drinking
on vodka soda and you know I'm waiting
for them to bring me a glass of ice so I
could fill it up with my special
concoction that I keep in my Hello Kitty
flask
oh that's a gorgeous blast what are we
drinking images men I know I'm a sweaty
man have sex with this man all right
thank you
I was drinking some Guinness what are
you drinking right ah moonshine that's
what I like to hear I'm hanging with
this guy buckets on it
there's my political choice from a class
the individual as you can tell I know
you're dressed to the nines I didn't get
the memo just like a slob what's going
on I don't know what it is I asked a
bartender make me a good drink so I saw
pour apart of vodka and then some fruit
juices what's in the flask damn it
this is cigarette I feel like he's pure
pissed okay he just drank GHB and Molly
mixed in with Jameson and codeine oh
yeah go ahead
so this guy gave me soup but it's
actually it's a real thing it's in oh my
god well you know what I'm a big fan of
new media rockstars you guys are really
filling the void I really love the focus
that you guys are putting on digital
video and what's happening in this space
because this is real news it's important
news and just look at the energy the
vibrancy here tonight with all these
creators doing what they do for
thousands of fans I mean last year
I was here during industry day that's
pretty low-key today on industry day
there are thousands of YouTube fans
shrieking over their favorite YouTube
stars is unbelievable there's number one